The player formerly known as most cops is.
What do you think the role of the
psychedelics will be in the future?
Marijuana will most likely be somewhat
legal everywhere in the u s and this may
push someone to try stronger.
Psychedelics.
Is this bad?
Let's start with the first one.
I have no idea what the role was.
Psychedelics will be in the future.
I know that the FDA just cleared ecstasy
for use for pro post traumatic stress
disorder.
So that's very interesting.
I know there's some very interesting
work being done at Johns Hopkins on
silicide mushrooms,
which seemed to be very
effective for example,
in helping people stop smoking.
I think that we don't know
anything about psychedelics at all.
I mean we know that they seem to have
an effect on the serotonin system,
but that's a pretty broad brush stroke.
Um,
I think there incalculably um,
peculiar and that they reveal things
about the structure of the world that we
are beyond ignorant about beyond ignorant.
But I have no idea what role
they'll play in the future.
I don't know what to think
about psychedelics at all.
Um,
marijuana will most likely be somewhat
legal everywhere in the u s and this may
push some to try stronger psychedelics.
Is this bad?
I suppose it depends on how they're used,
whether or not it's bad
and what the intent is.
I think there are very bad party drugs.
Psychedelics aren't,
aren't for fun.
I don't think that that's the
right way to use them at all.
I think they need to be used seriously
and they need to be used in a manner
that's life affirming and they need to
be used in a manner that's commensurate
with genuine exploration and they need
to be used carefully or they can cause a
lot of trouble.
So Carl Jung said,
beware of unearned wisdom.
And I think that's very wise.
So,
um,
anyways,
I hope that we continue investigating
them scientifically because there's much
to be learned there much more than we
can imagine as far as I'm concerned.